hi Samuel leaves here and in this video
I wanted to address specifically those
people that are in debt so if you're in
depth right now and you're thinking oh
my gosh before I even think about
becoming financially free I'm in to
become debt free and before I even think
about investing in property and let you
get rid of all these debts then this
video really is for you so stay tuned so
[Music]
as we're talking about debt I just
wanted to spell out the difference
between good debt and bad debt because
sometimes people think they're in debt
when actually it's good debt so it's
okay let me explain the difference good
debt is when you've borrowed money to
invest in an asset bad debt is when you
borrowed money to invest in a liability
good debt is okay bad debt is awful now
I'll give you an example if you've
borrowed money to buy a property
investment that's good debt has called a
profit
it's a never-ending spiral it's a
downward spiral and it's it's a very
very common problem in this country and
I get asked about it a lot so good debt
is okay most successful businesses most
entrepreneurs run off good debt bad debt
is a terrible never-ending spiral so if
you're in bad debt right now let's say
you've got a I had a friend and he was
in 16,000 pounds worth of bad debt and
he said to me you know what am I
supposed to do I've got 16,000 pounds
worth of bad debt he said you know it's
gonna take me ages to pay this debt off
so what what do I do how do I start and
what I said to him is that what you
focus on expands so if you're in debt
the very worst thing that you can do and
this is what he was doing is focus on
the problem focus on the debt because if
you do that what you focus on expands so
what I tend to tell my students to do is
instead of focusing on the debt is that
they're focusing on the problem to focus
on the solution to focus on making money
rather than paying off the debt
so I advised him to do this and I said
to him look don't think about the debt
and we in fact what he did I told him to
set up a standing order where he would
pay the debt off each month I told him
to clear up his credit cards and bank
him from ever spending ever borrowing
any money again which was going to be
used for investing in a liability and we
set up a standing order for him and I
said now forget it he's done he's
finished now you can never think about
it again and you can solely focus on
investing in property on making money
and you know what within literally I
think it was 14 months he was completely
debt-free
because he was focusing now on the
solution he was making more money he's
standing order was going on and after
about six months he reviewed it in the
up the standing order and it was
completely gone so if you're in debt
right now don't write yourself off don't
think you need to pay all off before you
start before you become a property
investor don't use it as an excuse don't
get yourself so wrapped up and let it
obsess your mind that you're in debt
just set up a standing order paid off
slowly and then move on and focus on
being a property investor and
entrepreneur a problem solver so I hope
that's helpful god bless you I'll see
you next time thank you so much for
watching if you benefited from that
video please do share it with your
family
friends for more videos like it you can
watch right here and if you'd like to
spend two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time